um we did okay from it we were pulling a
rent from it and we were happy with that
um i used to flip properties as a hobby
i used to live in them and turn them
over when
i was um working full time um so i knew
i was comfortable with that and one of
your strategies is brr and i
love that strategy yeah but when i
joined the academy my eyes were suddenly
open to
all the other strategies that are out
there and things i'd never even heard of
before like
rent to rent where you can create
something out and nothing with none of
your own money i mean that that blew my
mind that was amazing
um so yeah i really and you've you've
done some interesting things which we'll
talk about over the last few months
where you've basically set yourself up
financially for life
yes which is incredible yes um so
so you've i mean for a start talk to me
about what you're doing with the pub and
how you
have used the strategies in terms of
you know the development strategies and
talk to me about what you're doing
because it's incredible
so the pub's got a really really big
garden and it is still a little bit
derelict and run down so we're taking
we were before before covered we were
taking the money and we were slowly
renovating the pub but
people think oh you know why haven't you
just done it well the problem is it
takes a lot of money and time and when
you're open
15 hours a day you don't have the time
to do it and then of course it's late at
night you can't because your neighbors
are there
and obviously we're surrounded by a
residential area so when we came to
um thinking about it my partner and i
were talking obviously we weren't
trading
for half the week um because we weren't
doing the deliveries and takeaways and
we said well what can we do
and we kept coming back to our back
garden which used to be
um used for a long time ago it was used
as a court now it's just a garden
and it's a bit of a dumping ground and
we thought what a wasted space
right next to the city centre what could
we do with it and my partner was genius
he came up with
why don't we develop it and and and i
thought you know it's so obvious
um but had i not done the academy i
wouldn't have thought outside the box
and said well how do we develop it
i just said yeah build a house whereas
now we're thinking
what's the maximum profit we can pull
from it so we decided we'd get planning
permission for
commercial units now i thought well how
do i go about getting planning
permission i've never done that before
so after um what we did on the academy i
thought you know what i'm just going to
find a couple of architects and find out
and the first architect was brilliant
told us what we could do came out viewed
the property
did a few sketches and before we knew it
yeah we've got planning permission for
five
commercial units on our back garden that
is incredible
and not only are you going to be able to
um you know obviously add value to the
to the pub doing that but that's going
to give you an extra rental income yeah
how much how much
how much revenue will that produce each
month cash flow profit
cash flow profit we're looking about two
to two and a half grand that's
incredible
well chef with it yeah very much so i
mean that's that's you know
it might not sound like a great deal but
that's
they're small units and it's it's a dish
in addition to the pub so um
it basically helps the pub if the pub
still struggles we've still got money
coming in
if we come out of the lockdown we've
still got money coming in so it's
looking
you know it's really good for the pub
either way because it's on the pubs
you know land so yeah but you've also
been going like crazy